>> Greg: THAT IS HOW YOU SAY
FECKLESS.
AS YOU KNOW.
KIM KARDASHIAN VISITED TO TALK
PRISON REFORM.
AND HERE IS CNN'S CROWN PRINCE.
AND LAMENTING OUR PRESIDENCY
LACK OF SERIOUSNESS.
>> FORGET THE FACT THAT KIM
KARDASHIAN IS HERE IN THE WHITE
HOUSE AND WHAT PLANET THAT IS
RESEMBLING NORMAL.
SHE SHOULD NOT BE HERE TALKING
PRISON REFORM.
IT IS NICE, BUT NOT A SERIOUS
THING TO HAPPEN.
>> Greg: MR. SOPHISTICATED.
DOES THIS GUY EVER HAVE ANY FUN?
HE WOULD COMPLAIN ABOUT FRESHLY
LAUNDERED PAJAMAS.
ONLY THING I COULD GET.
I GET IT, KIM IS NOT THE
IMPORTANT CELEBRITY THAT SHOWED
UP WITH PRESIDENT OBAMA.
SHEEP'S NO JOHN LEGEND.
IS THAT RIGHT, JIMMY.
>> I WILL PUSH THE PRESIDENT TO
GET MORE VICTIM OFFED.
>> GIVE CNN THE SCOOP.
>> JOHN LEDGE ENLD, DON'T HOLD
YOUR BREATH.
>> WE MIGHT A LITTLE BIT.
AND THE FACT IS, A LOT OF
CELEBRITIES VISITED OBAMA.
JOHN LEDGE SXEND SEIN FELD AND
THAT NEVER BOTHERED JIM.
STEP OUTSIDE OF THEIR OWN BIAS.
EVEN IF TRUMP DOES SOMETHING
GOOD OR WHAT.SHAVE DONE.
THEY ACT LIKE IT IS A HORRIBLE
FIRST AND IT IS AWFUL.
AND TRUMP HEARS OUT A CELEBRITY
OVER A CASE OF A WOMAN WHO
SERVED 25 YEARS FOR A LIFE
SENTENCE.
DON'T YOU THINK ACOSTA WOULD
FIND THAT REFRESHING?
IT IS NOT ABOUT THE PRISONER OR
KIM, IT IS ABOUT TRUMP.
IT SEEMS LIKE JIM IS TUCK IN
A PRISON OF HIS OWN MAKING.
I CRAPPED IT UP WITH A NICE
LITTLE PACKAGE AND HAND IT OVER
TO YOU, JESSE.
CLEARLY A PRODUCT OF BIAS.
THE WHOLE STORY CHANGES.
>> Jesse: TAKE A LAP ACOSTA, YOU
GOT CRUSHED.
IT IS I POP CHRISSY AND HE TOLD
THE LATE NIGHT SHOW I WAS TOUGH
ON OBAMA AS I.
TRUMP.
HE GAVE OBAMA ALL OF THESE KESZS
AT THE PRESS COVERAGE.
I DON'T MIND.
YOU ARE IN THE TANK FOR THE LEFT
AND OWN IT.
DON'T HIDE BEHIND CNN.
YOU ARE BIASSED AND IF YOU ARE
ON THE RIGHT AND HARASSING
QUESTIONS AT OBAMA I AM SURE
SURE PEOPLE WOULD BE LAUDING
YOU.
I WOULD BE DOING A HELL OF A JOB
AND HE HAS A STOMACH FOR THIS.
THEY ARE CALLING THIS WOMAN WHO
KIM CALL WOULD.
FIRST TIME NONVIOLENT DRUG
OFFENDER.
SHE WAS RUNNING A COCAINE RING
WITH SOUTH COLOMBIA DRUG LORDS.
MAYBE IT WAS TOO HARSH.
BUT SHE SOLD A DIME BAG ON THE
STREET.
THAT IS AMOUNTS TO COCAINE FOR
MANY, MANY YEARS.
THERE WAS A LOT OF DRUG DEALERS
THAT SOLD AND DID FAR LESS TIME
AND THEY GET PAROLE.
WHAT ABOUT ACOSTA.
AND I HAVE AN AFFILIATION IN THE
SENSE THAT HIS DAD WAS A CUB AN
REFUGEE AND LATIN PRIDE IN ALL
OF THAT.
AND HE IS UPTIGHT AND
INCONSISTENT AND HE IS
DISRESPECTFUL OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
I THINK KIM KARDASHIAN GOING TO
THE WHITE HOUSE IS FABULOUS.
IF THAT IS WHAT IT TAKES TO TALK
ABOUT PRISON REFORM AND
SENTENCING REFORM.
>> Jesse: IT IS A BORING
PRODUCT.
>> Geraldo: THERE ARE SO MANY
CATASTROPHES COMPETING FOR
CENTER STAGE ON THE WORLD
PLATNORM.
YOU NEED SOMEONE LIKE HER TO
PUSH IT OVER.
IN AM DELIGHTED THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP PARDONED DENISSIA.
HE HINTED THAT ROD, THE FORMER
GOVERNOR OF ILLINOIS.
HE GOT 18 YEARS FOR SAYING I
CAN'T WAIT TO GET SOMETHING FOR
A SEAT.
AND PETER FITS GERALD WHO IS JIM
COMEY'S FRIEND.
HE WAS THE PROSECUTOR IN
ILLINOIS AND MARTHA STEWART.
SHE WAS IN THE CLEAR AND LIED TO
A FED AND DIDN'T KNOW YOU
COULDN'T TELL A MISTRUTH.
>> Jesse: LOBBY FOR A PARDON
JUST IN CASE.
>> Greg: AND FOR DANA AND JENNA.
>> YOU KNOW THAT PRISON REFORM
ACOSTA AGREED WITH THIS.
AND HE HAS TO TWIST IT.
AND BECAUSE IT IS TRUMP, HE HAS
TO OPPOSE AND HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH IT.
WHEN IT IS AN ISSUE THEY OPPOSE
IT IS ONE THING.
AND PROBABLY SUPPORTS AND MANY
PEOPLE DO AND YOU HAVE TO NAIL
JUST BECAUSE IT IS TRUMP, THAT
MAKE ITS SO FUNNY FOR THE
AUDIENCE, I THINK.
>> Dana: I WILL TALK ABOUT THE
CELEBRITY ANGLE AND I DON'T CARE
THEIR POLITICAL VIEWS AND I
DON'T TAKE MUCH STOCK IN THEM
AND IT DOESN'T PERSUADE ME AT
ALL.
ANGELINA JOLIE WHEN SHE TALKED
ABOUT THE PLIGHT OF CHILDREN AND
REFUGEES, THAT WAS EFFECTIVE.
>> Greg: YES.
>> Dana: AND SO IF YOU HAVE
A PLATFORM AND WANT TO DO GOOD,
THAT IS TO BE ADMIRED AND I
WOULD SAY ON THE PARDON FRONT.
IT WAS NOT THE PARDON I WAS
EXPECTING TODAY.
WE TALKED ABOUT MATTHEW CHARLES
WHO IS ACTUALLY BACK IN JAIL, IT
WAS A GOVERNMENT ERROR AND I
HEAR IS KICKED AROUND THAT HIS
SENTENCE WOULD BE COMMUTED AND
A PARDON POSSIBLY THIS WEEK AND
THAT IS MUCH MORE AWARDED.
>> Greg: HE DID DO JACK JOHNSON.